so the FBI has had physical possession
of Hunter Biden's laptop for more than
three years now on that laptop is
indisputable evidence of crimes Fair
violation gun felony influence peddling
and Hunter Biden of course has not been
charged by federal authorities he has
not been raided either because he didn't
pray in an abortion clinic but virtually
everyone who tried to investigate the
contents of that laptop has been under
attack from doj for part two of our new
documentary Biden Inc we looked into the
bite administration's efforts to crush
this story here's part of it nearly
every one of the high-profile players
involved in investigating Hunter Biden's
business practices have since been
arrested indicted or raided by federal
law enforcement Rudy Giuliani who
received the original copy of Hunter
Biden's hard drive had his home searched
and personal electronic devices seized
by the FBI Steve Bannon a former advisor
to Donald Trump who first tried to place
the hunter Biden laptop story was
arrested and charged with fraud the FBI
executed a search warrant the home of
Victoria Tenzing who'd worked with
ukrainians to uncover more information
about Hunter Biden's business practices
Lev parnas and Igor frumin who helped
Rudy Giuliani investigate Hunter Biden's
business dealings were both arrested on
campaign finance charges in October
2019.
foreign
once again that documentary is called
Biden Inc Parts one and two are now
available on Fox Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight